fan just found out about your podcast
this year a little late but listen to
every single episode my question is
what are your thoughts on guys wearing
earrings and this listener sent this in
because he's wearing them but he's
feeling a little self-conscious
a black guy is different is that a black
guy
brown guy oh wait brown could be a mix
actually those eyebrows are from groucho
a couple of caterpillars eh yeah
earrings and they look photoshopped on
there
there's studs or whatever you call he
wants to know can he still pull this off
is this cool do women look down on this
do guys think it's stupid i think it's
uh
it just doesn't matter if you're unsure
right and you already don't have the
confidence walking into it it will never
work for you
good point you got to own it baby you
know my left ear did you know my left
ears pierced
i love anything you're so confident i
remember the first time
i had sex with you you were wearing
cheetah printed panties not even men's
underwear yeah yeah women
and he was like dancing in a corner like
this yeah in a dark corner and he was
doing the air guitar
hilarious you would call that confident
i would call that
cry for help before i met my before i
met my current girlfriend i remember
them telling me that story
and i did that to a girl just to see
what would happen they work oh yeah
hey i think this guy's a [ __ ]
air guitar right with my pew laughs
right i stretch my pews out and i do
tunes on the
i stretch it out and i do tunes on the
[ __ ] uh i play stairway to heaven on
the [ __ ] thing
right that's so hard to do so hard to do
it's so intricate
my point is is that i've always been
like that you know
yeah so it's like this young guy it's
like you just have to
you know anything that it's like a
peacock right
yeah i always peacock it only males
right
it's like express yourself right
and i think that you know the loudest
you know the peacock is the one that
gets the most [ __ ]
not always what do you mean
stumped we've said time and time again
like i always think the loudest person
in the room always has the least to say
i agree
listen bro bro you don't have to
this is a 50 50 podcast bro all right
yeah you can agree with her and i'm fine
with it
right i'm not saying you're the loud guy
i'm just saying i'm
express yourself bro see how low you are
you're not loud at all yeah
that's right so um okay
yeah i don't think peacocking is the way
to go
i'm just saying love what you're doing
and do you do you don't ask people
you can't seek outward at validation
because that's just
a turn off makes the [ __ ] all right
good to know
i love an honest lady yeah keep it real
you have any other questions
yeah sure i'm 30 but now i've always had
a difficult time connecting with people
and felt like an outsider over the last
four years i must have talked over a
hundred women on dating apps meeting
dozens
and the only one i did feel a strong
connection with that really understood
me
um didn't like me and she ended up
toying with me and kind of broke my
heart